laredo
two
keeping
right huh
chips chips free da bag i could
get that's how it goes right before
we started recording yeah scott and i
were doing the the descending fames from
david bowie song fame fame fame fame
fame
vey vey vey vey very very food
and i gotta say what i bet
that was fun for a must-win fun
it must have been fun one to
say i bet it was fun for
lorna listen to that was is that
the one channel i actually don't remember
it happening
you remember us doing it yeah just
a minute ago yeah
um yes i believe he co-wrote with
john lennon right gentlemen renown right i
think they cole elaborate oh that's pretty
looks at pr team great mashup there
people with they also fucked each other
ah do you hear about the under
pressure that basically like they had an
agreement freddie mercury and david bowie that
they would each go into the studio
without hearing what the other person did
and just lay down something and they
would try to put it on top
of each other and see how it
came out and david bowie cheated and
listen to freddie mercury and came on
and added to it this man yeah
he's decided the better way to do
more to cheat sometimes yeah and that's
why most people do it that way
yeah if you're all feeling
what the song yeah why would they
agree to that
funny and probably a fun game you
know yeah but it's it's it's people's
jobs you're you're wasting people's time i
was going to imagine something cool happened
yeah but we'll never get to because
we have to listen to that shitty
under pressure song the way it is
i like cheaters version i love that
song to cheaters by the way there's
a new shoulders that's exactly where he
was fun as there's one show there's
a
new show that's just cheaters i saw
it's cheaters it's it's it's essentially true
but it's not called cheaters it's like
love trap or something like split up
it's a love trap oh i think
it's what's her name from tammy from
l a real world and from what
other reality show she in real world
road rules challenge no she's she's in
like one of the
the like housewives oh wow oh yeah
me
let me look it up the name
doesn't ring a tiny roman tell e
she's not on real housewives she's yeah
i said it was something like churlish
daskal why there you go that's fine
that is fine that is difficult basketball
wow
sharper ah gosh oh lauren
are you angry i'm angry sorry i
wanted to but yes
oh here she is okay anyway so
she's i think she's hosting it great
and it's ah it's i saw it
i was like this is just cheaters
the original host was telling me greco
that show was always fun to watch
you know on a hot summer's day
when you could be playing outside yeah
absolutely so i remember it yeah when
i was
an adult was tiny and playing outside
but you weren't you were inside watching
cheater i was doing my taxes are
watching cheaters god you're always doing your
taxes so cheaters have you're almost good
doesn't it feel like taxes go on
forever and ever yeah like you're like
it's a it's a whole quarter of
the year just spent getting that all
sorted yeah so yeah bullshit huh that
sorted sorted cheaters have you didn't watch
it was a show or rope watching
peppa pig where people would come into
people would come to tommy greco and
they would say i think my husband
gene i mean and then they would
follow the people around with a camera
and then find him cheating and then
they were and then they would come
right that real no i hear that
they were
all staged know everyone's an actor oh
yeah and same with all the jerry
springer and all that stuff oh good
but i mean what was going on
maury povich let's talk about that now
that apparently israel the father dna tests
because he was like when the i
saw something about him being like the
first person to do that and became
like his whole thing it was like
other people did it were like yeah
i think people to be eventually signature
move but other people did do it
other shows like
you would just go on his show
not even expand on the shows doing
you're like yeah we want to have
you on maury povich talk about your
dental hygiene
oh okay well anyway i got a
crown ticket out you are a father
the woman i slept with once what's
she doing here
you ever think about whether it's for
other guys have you ever thought about
whether you could have a baby out
there that you don't know about yeah
i've gamed it out and i feel
like i can't i don't think i
feel like i think i've i feel
like i would rack of everything like
i would have been told i think
that's mental at this point you would
but i feel like back then i
felt like
people would have grabbed me just to
shame me but you hear these stories
where it's just hey look at this
baby aren't you ashamed you did this
shit but i feel like i would
i feel like i pretty much heard
everything about everybody i think
like what they went on to do
in their life yeah and i would
like you don't know you don't know
everything and you don't know what happened
for them and you don't know how
it played out and you you never
can know saying right now i've narrowed
it down to just the women that
i've had penetrative sex jesus christ
extra managers i've ruled out the others
you don't know that couldn't other underwear
that was the kind of thing always
got put on like scary like of
the horror shows that you watch like
they didn't even have sex it was
like over the underwear and she's pregnant
it can seep through one strong like
a sigh one it's strong it seeps
through that's right it seeps through i
guess who's your favorite seinfeld character wow
chair michael richards off stage
jerry's your favorite no
clean is the best plain yeah the
answer is elaine maybe joe are fucking
funny on that show so funny so
pretty so talented she's just great i
mean damn i know they were a
dream team for sure there was no
xander was so good on that show
though it's hard to see him in
other shows because he's not new in
the george thing yeah in pretty woman
have you watched it yet no yeah
the heck
yeah he sees in that a mean
man i'm really not george like he
was great on my television show and
i asked him how because we just
put out offers to people never expecting
anyway and then he agreed to do
it right away and i said why
did you agree to do this he
said i just love the script
let's say it is like it is
a really funny script yeah yeah that's
very nice you never see his episode
of criminal minds know they're bringing that
back by the way oh yes i
know jay that's right as jay bruce
day he plays some sort of criminal
mastermind or something he's got like this
long white wig and he's doing some
kind of voice it's really
you have to see it adorable it's
worth taking potential cfcs i were with
comedians or someone died on stage or
whatever i mean george constanza criminal minds
roll i can't i've never seen it
i've only seen like like clips of
it gotta be very tempting to play
mastermind right i find when we do
is his idea where yeah here's what
i want to look like what would
be helpful to kind of break up
the yeah george of it all yeah
and also it's like hey wanna have
fun i mean i never have to
work wow wigs always won't wigs
alway it's hard to find like a
way in to be different to play
like a big criminal mastermind right because
you don't want to play at all
arch and like huh i know everything
about evie's paul dano did an okay
job in batman i think like where
he's just like skill kid almost but
i don't know well he seemed like
a a a a murderous lunatic to
me
guess i don't know but even that's
the other thing playing the joker how
did you find something new youth letter
he did a great job with it
but how do you like you know
cesar romero after that the ultimate i
mean joaquin funds being new yeah it
was different yeah he won an oscar
no joker had walked down steps before
well yeah they hadn't they built this
part of the movie from there like
how do we make this make sense
if you want to us you want
to oscar one and ask joe joker
oscar yeah one of the only roles
in cinema history that is two actors
of one four that's right what's the
other one well there's not a lot
of roles that are done over it
is ah like angelina jolie vito corleone
au trou de niro from joker and
my fan brandy peter o'toole is in
modern-day person to be nominated for playing
the same character in different things what
about different energies didn't she play a
queen and different she play queen elizabeth
in shakespeare in love did she play
queen elizabeth jim i think maybe i
don't know the hero who played henry
the second in a man not a
mentor seasons um
beckett and the lion in winter what
did you learn to cool up recently
a man for all seasons what did
you learn to cool up recently was
covert
um i don't remember recently wasn't so
i think i think you gave her
a movie and i think it was
meant for i'll see if that sounds
familiar it sounds like something you would
do it not so much lauren know
i would never i really never you
you hold my movie collection well i
write i'd lend a movie out but
it would never be a man for
all seasons like
what about women i'm talking about thirteen
going on thirty
speaking of women i've never seen little
woman i would love to watch women
i would love to watch that i
brought this up to bob odenkirk about
i asked him if he'd ever seen
the kababs and the new one which
is really good right that's what i
and you just kind of like shows
up out of the blue and everyone's
like yeah oh even it was shocking
to me and i knew he was
in the move i'd forgotten i
and then when he shows up it's
like well it's i don't know whether
that's because we know him but it
seems to have had that either horrible
as well because someone someone layered the
ah took a video of it and
layered his entrance with the ah i
don't know if you've seen the crowd
applauding it end game avengers endgame
but that's a great i have watched
that movie that's really okay so avengers
endgame someone on opening night took a
video of the crowd and recorded the
crowd's reaction to the big like and
wherever everyone comes back from yeah and
shows up and people are like going
crazy they layered that on balboa park's
entrance in little women and it's really
fun wasn't there wasn't there
like i feel like it was in
the most recent spiderman movie where all
three spider-man's were in it and like
when andrew garfield showed up there was
somebody recorded in the movie or like
there was a guy did backflips and
ah he couldn't express himself like a
month exactly been like i just have
to get this
yeah so funny he had to prep
for that and said oh man when
they show into yale but so so
probably he starts over maguire tobey maguire
and he's like okay i don't i
think while they shit y don't think
you can title those two phones should
condense them yes the one toe from
a grace till from grace to omega
race
oh my grace oh remember joe da
je suis grace grace grace bar
i was banging my foot in time
why are you doing i should not
be doing is you're fully healed i'm
sure it is because i was supposed
to get this off three days ago
but my doctor was on vacation so
i'm getting it off tomorrow i'm in
right field now it's a walking boot
but so i didn't need them to
remove it just because i can look
at it and go it's all good
i'm going to remove it they're just
gonna extra year the walk
although when i broke my other foot
when my brother ran over it i'm
sure i told this story in a
culture of oh wait jesus christ how
many times have you broken your feet
are trying to get away from me
i broke my heel they've had an
on this foot my ankle on this
foot my foot
foot foot on the worst wedding or
the worst one was this one when
my brother ran over i had to
be in a cast all summer so
that phone operation with the boot is
the same one from the other term
mature yeah and why did he run
over it i don't i'm sure yeah
what was his reasoning he was dropping
me off at the library where i
was volunteering awesome wow what a great
boy so because
you are a dork by the way
crunch
and i got out of the car
and i turned around to shut the
door in my foot was by the
the wheel and i hadn't shut the
door whenever he just took off and
yelled out and i not be like
nah he rolled onto it and i
went ah wow and then he rolled
back on to it
and just to undo what he did
yeah yeah and then it was they
tried to convince me not to tell
their police
he's like just walking off it's fine
don't do not tell just walk it
off yeah and i was like it
really hurt i can't walk around thirteen
or fourteen o fourteen sad and ah
so then ah told them and went
to the hospital and got a cast
on it but the one thing that
i was thinking about the other day
because i've been i have to take
this boot off to shower and stay
if like that yeah um and
the showering or taking it off taking
the boot off okay um but because
i know you do a little dance
and you put you nicely
yeah lap it's breathing but when i
got the cast off my my foot
after the whole summer of being on
it was just like itchy as fuck
and there's nothing that you a little
white like you basically put a coat
hanger down it and try to start
showering yeah when they took it off
there's
like a giant leaf in there
teaching goes well yeah giant leaves are
like lee oh this must have been
causing use and discomfort like yeah i'm
sorry that's so crazy a leaf a
leaf that'd be so annoying what a
loose cast yeah don't know i think
it was already in the news when
you know it wasn't there
put it on me in the junk
al-fresco
they actually sealed it up and there
it was stuck to his butt now
of course you did have all your
earthly possession sealed up of course one
leaf three mobs um no i was
i was volunteering for like a kids
camp that summer too so i think
i was outside a lot didn't you
know on crutches and leaves
just blew in kids were stuffing leaves
in your calves yeah probably kind of
new kick me thing like a new
kick me sign to shutting leaves down
if someone signed your cast and said
shove leaves in here yeah when you
get cannibals i mean this is the
plot of dear evan hansen but it's
like it's it it's a lot of
pressure of like people going through window
oh
but i don't know any of the
songs i've never saving through her when
i hear the movies but the movie's
not good but the bombing was great
and i actually listened to the soundtrack
before i saw the show which i
never do i really enjoyed it but
i made up my own story of
what was happening and it wasn't funny
yeah what was the story you made
up in my version um
the evan dear evan hansen or the
character was secretly gay and he and
that guy were having a relationship because
i didn't understand the letter of it
all because of course i didn't have
ready dialogue necessary domain number two indeed
what was the context clue yeah um
as i thought that was a whole
storyline and so i was like kind
of making all the songs make sense
with
making the whole storyline i recommend the
nineteen ninety four little women over the
more recent one oh row saw that
one back in the day but i
would watch again with wine owner yes
jug yes i know just love when
no-no writer know she's still alive i
don't still alive oh naomi oh best
way i apologize to the entire
judge grimm i was very sad yeah
that's not something you want to see
her memorial was great okay um and
why not tell was very funny at
it oh really yeah yeah cracking wise
she's cracking wise she was like doing
a roast of her dear old mama
and it was and it was really
funny i was i'd never seen her
speak that much
much less make jokes it was really
funny okay i'll have to check that
out for a good time here's a
four good time i'm hearing wanna time
here's why i say that is because
the nineteen eighty four one is told
linearly and the the most recent one
shifts back and forth in time it
feels for
for just arbitrary reasons when it's become
like that's such a thing now where
people are telling stories out of order
and meanwhile let's go back eighty minutes
earlier yeah anyone saying it is a
thing to when we were eating lunch
yeah janney was watching a show that
was in i think it was in
dutch am
and it's about the this cast of
characters i'll think in the present and
in when they were like in their
twenties ah but the people in their
twenties look absolutely nothing like that's not
good people so it's you'll nothern has
to go on you got passed as
close to that as you pause yeah
you have to you know i think
senior year did a good
job with casting the characters i think
it was a good job i think
she is just so talented the person
playing the younger rebel she's great and
she was on she isn't an avengers
movie yes um and she's also in
the nice guys and she's great what's
oh
the nice guys was good um yeah
she was talented and it was really
enjoyable alright nice guys i haven't seen
but i mean um it's fun it's
really it's really what's nice guys it's
ryan gosling and russell russell crowe and
then andrew rice is her name yeah
she's australian oh so she i thought
she's doing the act now she's just
american and american x and all the
yeah she's so far from
a home yes she's so funny in
the spiderman movies yeah she's playing betty
brandt and she's like doing the terrible
almost between different style like terrible journalism
like school journalism videos she's very she's
really has the relationship with the with
nose yeah best friend yeah i haven't
seen any of those tom island spider-man's
but i've heard they're great it's
actually odd that i have seen them
in you haven't i know feels wrong
and the universes bet she's also in
something called daisy quagga world's scariest animal
while coca cola quagga quagga we met
we know we missed em wow mister
she is a cartoon and she plays
a qualquer i believe it is a
cartoon um and she i mean she
plays
daisy cauca so maybe the name of
the show that's pretty good to have
you're not only in the title but
on the title maine kwaku hey oh
oh
no noise so al pacino he does
yeah does does let's let's break it
down he does have a woman now
and he got spot da da da
da je know you all back in
the world is out but yeah so
he he does he doesn't have a
woman
any comes up with this noise right
haha and it gets an oscar for
it by boosh boosh but why don't
we come up with noises as actors
you constantly do it in what you're
right you're right and it's ah it's
ah it's it's like basically making these
stallions yeah you know like oh he
only
you did that noise in that one
movie that's what i'm saying but it
was enough to catapult him to the
oscar and now anytime you do an
al pacino impression it's like what does
noisy does oh haha yeah you know
or you say say hello to my
little friend sorry sis has got a
great ass and that's what we do
of course the devils reject devils wears
bra
the double why that oh what was
i wanting can a bad the devil's
advocate yeah
so what noise would you do if
i could do any noise in a
film well i think you have to
provide the character yeah because i'm like
okay i'll glue always a marine i'll
make it worse she's a character's she's
a high powered attorney who defends she's
defense lawyer she's high-powered gets paid a
lot for it oh i have one
for
or this and she but she goes
when she goes home she has three
little tiny mice that she takes care
of and she's always thinking about the
mice whenever she's at work and she's
always think about work whenever she's with
the mice my time i was doing
that yeah opportunities was just because he
was in the marines yeah but i'm
a lawyer and i go home and
think about law but
ah is when i'm at work i'm
only thinking about the mice yeah what
noise would you do i'd go like
this
i covered both is not bad if
you were to do that in a
movie i think it would be very
funny
ah look we have to take a
break we're gonna hear paul's noise when
we come good cliffhanger this is great
wow i love this
and we're back whoa so soon so
soon and soon i'm sam rosen and
paul was a genius yes and she's
been talking about it's a mister show
reference since senior balloon soon soon euro
balloon just one of the funniest lines
i don't know what properly is why
did they get you wrote on this
you know it's bob
said that to david cross yeah it
was it was a sketch about a
what a hate group a white supremacist
group where they only had one white
member
and bob was in brown faces an
indian man
okay back back oh yeah yeah yellow
faces jeff that was all good just
fine so it was a tribute to
this bp um i had somebody wants
said that to be about like an
older person said that to me years
ago about blackface about like minstrel shows
that was a tribute to blackberry alright
she drew um and ah
so so david at one point like
when are we going to do the
hate crimes or whatever and we're like
a revolution you know and david saying
he's soon soon and bob goes suit
suit your balloon and it was very
hard not to say oh he's so
funny it's just one of those lines
where you know how eh
anyone who thinks exactly yes yeah so
good yeah i'm alright okay so like
what's paul's character lauren paul your character
is okay so it's kind of like
a reboot of mister mom okay so
you're managing like all the household three
whatever it takes yes and you're like
you got a lot to do and
it's also got
you got to do and it's like
you have your ceiling always sweeping you're
always cleaning and you're always nursing the
baby with a bottle and you're just
kind of you have your hands full
all the time yeah well baby involved
and normally you're a baseball player but
you had to take off because the
mom says it's eat three regular seasons
under the water
come on you're almost there mom could
norvell your mom's mom so this is
like tired made a november ah it's
during the caesar in the actual season
am i a major league player yeah
you're in the m i'll be okay
alright so that is it yeah so
that's it mister mom usually
the baseball player very beleaguered have to
do all this stuff also not doing
my job which i like to do
because my wife is putting the family
right
ah oh it's almost out of here
almost by an umpire but yeah it's
it has like faint memories of his
time playing baseball but he knows you
can't really go there all the way
now because he's technically mr ma yeah
he doesn't realize he's
almost saying i'm out of here i'm
getting notes of persimmon yeah
i paul was like what's bad character
oh shit that's right no falls to
be a book right
yeah put up the tv
doobie guys were recording the doobie doobie
can you imagine she had no idea
i was looking thought to be whenever
she was part of the doobie clubs
so she can't know scott you're a
pothead okay but you're also
a thoracic surgeon
and
the hospital has been condemned and you
are you know you're doing surgeries while
a wrecking ball is smashing into the
other end of the hospital is my
noise surprised at the wrecking ball or
is this up to you it's your
knowing me your character okay
huh okay
right i'm gonna pretend to smoke a
doob first i'm yom pretend mining we
all didn't get to do that by
the way we didn't get to act
out full scene we didn't get to
ask when you didn't and neither of
you chose to do it fuck okay
now i'm not writing i hate when
he's right me too said noise wrecking
ball
i only ah yee oh my god
i see that you're gonna do that
in a lot of films so mad
about perfectly this um is this water
for me i'm assuming it is yes
ma'am drink it
let's all watch lower and drink water
i guess she did it
what do you think tastes almost here's
the thing about water taste like nothing
but it tastes like something you know
what i'm saying it's odorless it's flavor
list it's water everyone you know it's
really good to live why don't you
guys talk i'm gonna get mine because
i'm now in jail oh good luck
you've got to get head there he
goes he's got a
get his he's got a stumble and
fragrance oh yeah hey
my you don't fall down we don't
we can't we can't work together to
lift you up you know that i
was gonna say we can't lose you
but that doesn't like to pay anyone
that suck
if he felt this let's make is
there another glass in the cabinet make
a deal right now if he ever
falls down we're not picking them up
there's no way it's like i will
call an ambulance no matter what the
circumstance calls scrapped i'll call a task
rabbit yeah
you don't got his water okay good
he's all set
hey hey where are we going to
talk about we've about you and how
much we love you yeah oh how
much is it not my mother would
not pick you up that's not very
much it's as far as my arms
can extend
but it's compared to like the universe
y'all need to enough we all need
to get out to fit in here
y'all need to duke it out and
i'm hugging it oh yeah
so so yeah what's up yeah lauren
what's up why did you call you
want to ask you a serious question
like if you would if you had
slid to the floor was lava yeah
yeah and you were on the couch
could you jump up to that fan
and hold on wallets on spinning you
as you could fly and fling yourself
out the door well i mean that's
the dream isn't it yeah
yeah yeah i could
you actually think you could yeah do
you watch lors lava and go like
these fucking idiots i've never watched flores
lava but if i did i'm sure
i would i'd like to watch though
i know somebody who's on it oh
who's that ah her name is alyssa
cbo she was contested she's been contested
in a lot of game shows names
familiar to me oh my episode of
of that show that i did was
coming out soon where the game show
the hundred thousand dollar pyramid yeah oh
it was fun maybe here i don't
even know probably already aired yeah because
on september do they use the same
oh well i think it already aired
now oh dad to to to to
data data data data tent and i
do that
turn turn turn turn into that that
i want to be like that i
want to be on a game show
once a month how do i make
this happen i need to like know
i mean there's ways i think we
can film why don't you tell your
agent yeah and i'm sad i bet
you can make that happen that's true
can i represent you for only nine
percent
no because i don't think you'll do
anything yeah i will yeah
if i make but i won't make
any money that's true but neither will
i should if i make it happen
haha
can i get because your your thing
is you just want to be on
the game show that's the fun of
it yeah right that's it for now
so i would say if i could
make you if i could get you
on a game show me myself i
can make this happen get your game
show once a month yeah fifty percent
that's low that's so much to ask
for no but he but you just
want to play the game you would
do spree but it's not why exactly
it's a little bit of both it's
yeah a little bit about fifty percent
is a little bit yeah
perfect amount i don't know yeah i
don't trust you guys huh the little
nerd a lot you don't need to
be nervous on the freak in your
best interest don't freak out so do
you ever like look here i'm even
go i really did it
she's talking to scott obviously i'm just
sitting here looking at me
why but i wish i were fit
why you don't you ever say that
i wish i were famous enough so
that i could be on game show
each that just liberty guessed your mood
but i also wish i was famous
enough that people knew how to spell
my name that is actually driving me
crazy at this point when i see
this point it's like come on google
it here's what's really shitting you're typing
someone's name googly shit if you're typing
someone's name onto so we predicted the
bear i think should make sure you're
spelling it correctly but here's the thing
i get why people think they they
hear it and they and they think
they got it but most most usually
by the time i'm seeing it like
on a placard or something like happen
to comicon it's because it's been written
down by the initial person who thought
they knew how to spell right yeah
and then would also just cop why
does anyone think it's thump kins anyway
it's it's either falcons
because with each and the p yeah
because of that yeah or it's ah
t o m k ins or it's
t h o m k ins but
the new thing is to what it
actually the only time i ever encountered
those spellings is when someone is spelling
my name incorrectly because tompkins is not
a name because when you see your
own name right
you're very aware of it it's not
a name that i come across that
often when the only time i see
those spellings is when someone is spelling
my name wrong right it's really weird
that is weird i looked should my
name have an h in it it
should i'll i'll say right now of
course it should should you change equally
chain yeah yeah sure i can't i
can't tell my family but at that
time i was shoot
and um with a person that i
just met that day and they were
also in the thing but we were
um using our real names in the
thing and you could say it's curb
your loses saturday city it's definitely not
this is a long time ago but
anyways so we couldn't tell her why
suzy it was a year
year ago and i know it wasn't
kurt it was um not a it
wasn't a scripted thing and her busy
oh god her why are you dancing
around the floor we weren't acting oh
curb ah and um this person like
we'd been doing really for like four
hours the girl and then about to
come back and
shoot another piece and then she was
like how do you pronounce your name
again
i was like lauren i think she
just had no idea what it was
but that was her way to head
she avoided using it i guess but
i'm like first of all i said
my name in it well the second
of all it's okay if you missed
that but just ask me just say
i totally spaced somewhat your name yes
well it's the way to to couch
like of course i didn't forget
your name i just don't know but
it's like my name is so basic
i know but that's she thought like
she was hoping it was something that
was comprised there's i forget so there
was a comic that had a bit
about that about a way to try
to get if you forget somebody's name
and it's like oh yeah you spell
might have been glass because you spell
it for me yeah j i m
ah
taught todd's think the other day about
about if someone's have you boring
yeah jeff buffer isn't good you can
hear him loudly just making noise like
this every every seven years
yeah and then a friend comes to
the door because is everything alright he
goes oh yeah yeah just using the
bathroom yeah
says everything
then he comes back and goes so
hey man i was really interested in
what we were talking about what were
you saying and then the person starts
to retail it and he goes oh
i'm getting a call and then he
puts the phone up to his ear
and it's obviously the record you made
in the other room he's like what's
that honey badger oh no i have
to go because my father's diet
yeah and then suddenly the person knocks
on the door hey what's going on
yeah that's a it
so it's friday it's really hard yeah
i yeah i'm glad that he's he's
been doing these i haven't bits on
on instagram housing yeah it's really funny
i gotta follow him you see
not taking on anymore instagram clients though
you gotta make room for todd make
room for ty mute somebody else get
out in there because he's doing this
thing now where he's he taught he's
talking to an empty chair
because words we live in a microphone
and then an empty chair with microphone
in front of it and like the
the one he did most recently was
like i was watching judge judy and
usually she's pretty fair with either she
sits like
guys just brings me so much joy
yes i love people really just silly
assholes he's a fucking dickhead
um
yeah well i'm sorry to talk about
someone other than you know i don't
know him but i'm happy to hear
the stories and he sounds great and
i'll check out his instagram content i
love it she's so jealous right now
no i'm not i'm really happy god
no i was not your color rarely
am i'm a really happy for him
i'm happy you guys love his stuff
we'll look at your stuff no i
don't want to do instagram content i'll
look at your one thousand dotted lines
of high bachelor watch i wait to
do that until a little bit later
in the season this was it's just
too much smart but it will be
happening soon and if you wanna hear
me on some bachelor i was on
r yeah well
you accept this rose over by now
i think so too
oh shutter i have been watching esports
island by the way cool off and
i have just the f stand for
fuck oh no yeah and paul know
they spray it too
my friend created the show yuan elon
musk i like it we cool up
like way more than the bachelor i
think it's good i started watching it
but i didn't finish but i have
so many shows that i have to
watch and it's hosted by nikki glaser
yeah she's good too i have my
list is ever winding and i was
just
having a conversation with some friends and
they releasing on these shows that we
should all watch you're all telling we're
all sharing recommendations and they were majority
british shows and yeah let's cut british
shows just right out know what's great
about british shows la times will be
six episodes it's just i know great
episodes and you're just like yep that
was awesome
i'm like i like that it's very
manageable and american tv is now getting
that manageable with streaming yeah two episodes
are you think so well to the
actors and people who make them detriment
yeah it's more fun to photograph famous
people that are in five tv shows
i think they're doing okay that is
true people do get to do a
little business sucks
oh why did we bother it sucks
getting luckier when there's so many times
we're actors being like five shows and
i'm like why are they allowed to
do that when i feel like i'm
never allowed to do more than one
thing every fucking to any contract i've
signed it's like yeah can't do this
or that i'm like this guy's doing
he's doing a game show yeah this
guy other thing because they won't sign
those contracts and you will
wow that hurts my fleet we came
calling me oh listen i'll poke from
me me me me me me he's
calling for his name i wish my
mamie was oh you remember your maybe
too vaguely i've been having a lot
of dreams okay i'm having
a weird thing lately where i actually
feel very i'm feeling very positive and
very um like excited creatively about the
things that i'm doing and really enjoying
them but i'm having weird stress dreams
where things are not going well right
but i'm not feeling like the day
daylight fear of that stuff like i
often have in the past so it's
very strange to me that i'm having
these these classic stress dreams that i
used to have when i was feeling
that way all the time do they
relate to something else in your life
though and and your brain is just
reverting back to oh this is the
stress dream that night
to get out of my marriage but
oh oh well no i don't need
no i don't i don't know if
it's like if it's like the vestiges
of that feeling that i've just made
with just so long maybe just everyone's
while they trot out the classics yeah
you know the one i had recently
was great because it was
and they always always always will be
at my childhood home and like it's
it's like in the house in my
cousin house who were right next door
because we lived in a duplex and
this interesting that you're actually going that
yeah yeah um did you say suplex
right above the duplo was established on
a previous episode so it was all
the callback it was winter it was
winter and there was like a kind
of in the in the we we
shared this big backyard
the screen hey guys this is good
sh and i'm all whoa whoa no
it's not it's it's just winter it's
not christmas oh boy i don't know
third doors oh he left i see
them delivering you hell i'm filtering the
mail it's january ninth nobody's there oh
i'm all by myself
i buy and so i'm walking around
the back of my house towards my
cousin's house in our yard and our
shared yard was all water was frozen
over but i knew there were sharks
in there ooh and these were the
kind of sharks that could like kind
of edge out of the water a
little bit different like town
no but they look like sort of
like whales like small whales but i
remember like so i was walking past
and then one got out of the
water and like was trying to get
home and i'm walking away from it
like hey like if you saw like
a dog in your neighbor a stray
dog come on seem like it was
being kind of dicey yeah
and ah and i was walking around
the corner and this shark was like
still he couldn't get me but he
was still trying to hang yeah and
i was just kind of watching him
in fascination and of course the scary
was shark so and this is this
is related to something this is one
you've had often or this show i'm
interested ever had that one
oh okay i had one and i'll
tell you off mike that's a classic
for me but i have a new
spin on an old classic i had
an earthquake dream the other night boo
and i really thought i woke up
and i was like oh had a
dream on earthquakes and i went on
twitter and typed an earthquake just to
see because you know people always tweet
when there's an early love it and
no there wasn't
what an interesting story yeah jamie has
a good ability to feel earthquakes yeah
so he's always tweeting about them she
sheet but she will i will learn
about them from her editor but she
will also feel a lot of false
earthquakes oh and it's like if she
just wakes up in the middle of
that she's a hurry quick
i'm like no no no i think
there's no earthquake where the great
every single day look like hey okay
alright what's triggering earth break
and we're back and we are we
have to be back at this point
right do me introduce yourself yeah why
wouldn't we have
i think we forget sometimes if we
did is the third segment people have
to have googled i feel like we
owe it
we will have some just like wait
who are these three what happens couple
lauren by the way there used to
be ah you know how shazam you
can hold a song that's playing up
to of course solomon hercules and achilles
shoes
atlas atlas and mercury yeah so that
back when they first invented there was
a different app that you could just
hum a song into anyone tell you
what it was back then there was
yeah it was and then then it
went out of business or whatever and
it happens to me so much i'm
like what is this laredo
ah and i've missed that app gaming
reps yeah but i'm doing an obvious
one but ah sorry how about this
how about this matter da da da
da
whenever i'm down siri what is this
all beauty de de mary had a
little lamb no but there's a new
app that does or no google google
whatever does it now so i just
heard about this so happy google whatever
yeah google chef google whatever it you
can sing a ditty to it you
just
digging into it and it will go
you are listening to i want it
that way or whatever wow that's really
amazing like saying doo doo doo doo
doo doo doo doo doo dude that's
right yeah let's try right now
hello ma daughter
ah here i am a damn good
nah
hello ma let's try it let's try
it i wanna see if i don't
how do you do it i've never
heard the one that told me i
can dream about you fuckin you to
teach shit
so what's the song oh fuck i
looked at sing and it's saying sing
to send to ah rita tara
okay i'm gonna look up what song
is this
okay what is this song oh news
this
a i don't know how to do
it paul i just thought i'd mention
it well thank you i appreciate that
and teach them inefficient all that i
get you yeah whatever um it's time
for reacher fuck sorry
this one's called play it again
oh yeah i'll refresh my memory okay
i don't think i recall we play
three film critics one of us suggest
a classic movie that shouldn't have a
sequel and then are three film critics
describing the sequel to that film i
don't think we've done this we've done
it i think yeah it sounds familiar
okay familial um and then
we we talk about the plot we
talk about the title we talk about
why it should have been made shouldn't
have been made what we think of
it all like oh great so learn
do you want to throw out ah
any movie hey can i make an
adjustment yeah i'm living we have to
talk about why it should or shouldn't
be made i think the fun is
creating the sql movie that should not
have a sql okay you want to
shut down anyone who talks
about why it shouldn't have been and
i will if you started to start
fucking make noise okay lay down on
the ground okay okay i want you
to promise me that oh it is
by your promise to you ah that
the that the google what is this
the the the the data
oh hello hello ma hello hello bara
the movie is
serendipity
hey everyone welcome back to we watch
the movies so you don't have to
remember that it happened but i don't
remember the story my co-host are having
a conversation and we're already rolling it
john yeah yeah ok
oh hi everyone here's a little peek
behind the curtain yeah sorry we were
just kinda catching up with the first
one a little bit hope you don't
mind yeah anyway welcome to the show
wonder our rating suck shit that's another
thing that you don't have to talk
about while the cameras everyone knows everyone
knows i know not everyone was weaned
on that point hey
uae yeah we know we suck ok
re i do a deep dive on
the ah the new sequel to the
classic movie serendipity lowering joan cusack john
cusack john hughes john cusack daughter katherine
that's adsl oh i thought catherine zeta
jones isn't the first one i guess
oh it's kate beckinsale shit roman ah
or whatever her name is who is
later to be seen in sex in
the city yeah big's new wife well
in any case it's new wife obviously
happened to either of us have seen
the first one but we first did
while this child is lost in this
yeah and by the way it's called
seren tuesday the serendipity
the first one of course is about
john cusack meets a woman by chance
yes yeah right sorry phone number in
the book love in the time of
cholera sheep gets she y hands it
off to orange puts it on a
five dollar bill i don't know what
happened and they each exchange their number
busy looking at link they let they
put a she put one phone number
in a book and one phone number
on a dollar
and they send those off into the
world and they go for hey if
it's meant to be it's meant to
be we'll meet again cut two years
later she he's getting married to somebody
else oh no good and should get
maria's lou finally find his number connects
with them find him all that stuff
and it's serendipity how they meet
now of course the sequel we have
them just living their daily lives yeah
we have a family together their mayor
what i thought was really interesting was
he did this for all of his
children he wrote his name on five
dollar bills and just left them lying
around that yes and if you figure
this out then i'm your dad what
i thought was interesting about it and
i'm not saying this
this is good but i thought was
interesting is that it's almost like a
reverse link later where instead of revisiting
these characters taking years to catch various
points in life it's one twenty four
hour movie yeah and it's twenty four
hours after their wedding which i thought
was really interesting they adopted all these
children in that twenty four hour it's
really you know not a lot huh
happens in the day no and you're
very tempted or sleeping they're sleeping for
they get daily hours of it but
you don't want to miss anything when
kenny that the filmmakers seemed to know
when you the audience member will be
dropping off to sleep because loud noises
start yeah right yeah alarms fire alarms
smoke alarm yes yeah all sorts of
stuff that the people on screen can
hear because they're dubbed in later
no they're not it's part of this
techno undertake to keep us awake these
characters can't hear this yeah in case
you're wondering why they're not react which
sort of made me mad anytime i
would wake up at you know jarring
awake and then see that these people
the worse thing i'm learning is like
they're they're sleeping peacefully yeah yeah yeah
here's why i didn't think this movie
should be made oh i thought we
were paying more
you two siskel and ebert always fighting
okay i won't talk about it sorry
i think it should have been made
because obviously it's a horrible idea i
think why should have been made is
because we need to know more about
these characters we go we watched the
whole first film we'd all go where
they go this is the first film
that truly answers the question is there
a happily ever after yes but how
many times you watch a movie in
the movie ends and you go now
what are they
oh no it should go why why
are all these names on i do
that three players they go into these
are they all right are they dead
that's why first i was a day
off remains the best movie because at
the end the filmmakers take care to
have the main character come out and
say go home the movie is over
thank you we and i appreciate never
any other bow off and i do
don't know what happened and i'm scared
yes yeah i'm frightened lights come up
i'm like i'm even more frightened now
that lights are up yeah absolutely the
world and the screen has disappeared and
as my world asbjrn exactly can people
see me my ghost yeah and this
film takes care of that and in
a really interesting way and i also
love what the film is that it's
all new actors playing the roles that
looked none
nothing like the original cat absolutely nothing
like them ah there's a difference in
ages of about forty years yeah um
and they're all they're all birds as
well i mean we can spoil it
but rockers you've seen the trailer you
know that they're all birds i thought
i was also weird that the the
actors playing the parents were also playing
the children and i would say they
were able to rang
like themselves yeah and they were double
check to their single lines at the
center like one suggestion i would give
like i liked how it was called
seren to pity yeah but i feel
like could have been seren two can
pity yeah because of the birds yeah
yeah also sarin gas two k pithy
was it was one title i thought
of what does that mean oh i
just haven't be good
i thought a good title will be
serengeti to pity if it had been
alliance instead of sharing getty typically yeah
you heard me i thought was interesting
how one scene in the middle of
the actors understudies played and what i
thought was weird was i was called
usually we're holding stairs it's actually called
serin get a tipi tonight to notice
tenants well i on the whole praise
the movie for the concept i think
the concept is flawless yeah but the
execution was a little lacking for the
execution in the scene in the middle
of the execution scene yeah it was
gross and yeah well i didn't die
it was really raw and you know
they gave miss last me
real and he wanted ice cream i
thought okay i'm gonna watch me to
gallon of ice cream really the bird
when they behead him in the guillotine
than the ice cream spills up the
neck it's like i didn't have and
it was like another bird starts eating
it oh my for it was he
didn't get to digest it yeah i
mean you don't even give them a
minute it was also store brand ice
cream which i thought was real slap
in the face it was kroger i
thought that was kind of like
we have just for the sake of
the film spent a little more ice
cream briars a haagen dazs just his
last is his last meal i mean
look i don't know i don't believe
i don't agree with the crimes he
committed but i feel that he could
have had briars and haagen dazs and
for me as someone who's gonna be
executed tomorrow morning i thought is this
what i can expect you can tell
us it's tamago music
oh yeah they finally say up yeah
oh congratulations they said they got sick
of my complaining and so they he
moved it up because you kept saying
when when when yeah yeah and there's
like quando quando yeah yeah i was
thinking
and um and so yeah i'm getting
excused tomorrow ah for my last meal
yeah what are you doing i i
i did an end run because i
thought i bet the quality of the
last meal is not that good so
i said i want a swanson tv
dinner because i know what that is
i know what to expect got it
um i'm getting the salisbury steak mashed
potatoes and the little apple pie you
do worry it won't be
yeah that's fine oh i forgot it's
only heat it up they might give
it to co no frozen i didn't
think any of us yeah bro i
requested watch frozen two things that kevin
had a parrot but what's that you
have to tell them how to prepare
it yeah i guess that's allowed the
last detail yeah yeah yeah so i
think anyone would know to put it
in the microwave because a lot of
times people asked for fried
chicken ah they'll just get a chicken
and a fryer and then they have
to do it themselves yeah that's tedious
now that you've had a consuming like
a friar like people to make their
own last meals do people understand that
the prisoners know or don't don't and
don't order something too complicated yeah because
you're going to be there all night
i'd say if i simply p b
and j was just gonna say yeah
you just stop
together anyway i mean slapped together i
thought this movie like why didn't the
other movie right why didn't they turn
the cameras on well it was all
supposed to be audio i think that
was like a sort of so strange
because you could hear them go should
return these on and if someone didn't
know don't worry about they didn't edit
that out which was the point of
the polaroids but they described the ice
cream pouring out of his neck and
at
the point is some of it was
the descriptive yeah yeah and we also
we don't even know if that's actually
what happened yeah oh yeah oh hey
i mean that's how you save on
it probably was with a they'd probably
didn't film anything because i remember it
was the director's voice at the very
beginning saying this is this is what
happens to the movie you'll have to
take my word for it yeah and
he talks for like three of the
twenty four
hours wow describes all of the twenty
four hours and then we just sit
there in silence and black yeah yeah
anyway great movie yeah five stars for
submit my own rating which is twenty
seven forks spoons with a side of
potatoes these are not sporks know for
experience yeah yeah got it and where
do you give me i mean it's
the last mu
ivvy you're ever gonna see it well
i want to say very quickly a
friend of mine's son he's two years
old and he pronounces the name forty
from toys fucking and it's very funny
that's funny yucky got to find funky
fucking um what about saki ah i
don't think there's a character called sarki
maybe the west wing aaron sorkin shore
um
i'm gonna give this a rating of
b b like b movie so in
a plus
no o be like the the the
the the the bib the bib billy
bathgate oh billy babbitt and that's to
behave young to get to these two
babies wow incredible amazing and what did
you give it to charity do it
a plus eight plus love love love
love was so confused the entire time
i lie
loved it well that feeling just sitting
there going what am i who am
i where am i where am i
why
yeah well that's about all the time
we have i just want to let
everyone know i will be giving the
locations of some of the bodies um
oh gore i'm executed you should yeah
that's my plan i mean that you
decide this will air after the that
happens but i i'm so i'm not
i mean i'm not i don't wanna
know no real i'm gonna do all
but one will just make the debate
interesting for them or you
okay oh my god no
naturally this is not just this with
big thumbs
under the library
like the library or the we have
to carry the library under the library
okay i'm not gonna check it out
i wanna go to saudi air i
remember people can do it yeah they
can do what they want anyway um
you want to get out of here
yeah yeah your order you want to
get a drink oh dad drinks now
klee you want me to order the
you want me to call the bar
walk and i'll get yeah hi why
do you have i live in the
floor
keyboards are dough okay we're gonna have
to gimlet it's the game let's caffeine
out oh i want a harvey well-being
no no by nah yeah he'll have
what i ordered him he will have
what your irving yes you will
see yeah
we did it we fucking crush that
guy we crush that shit way fucking
cross i don't remember if we've ever
i don't think we ever have it's
i felt new and fresh exciting and
you say hey da da da da
look you dumb asses here's what you
need to know where at threesome usa
at gmail dot com if you wanna
write
it to us send us an attachment
of some kind just a gif spy
when you that's a gif everyone wants
a gif were so upset that no
one sending gifts yeah and segev it
oh a gift well you want yes
i do a gift over email i
want i want
complete set aside but we're running dangerously
low we only have five in this
room we're down to our last five
bad guys and they're all in graves
you can of course leave us a
voicemail at haha law in poo haw
haw law in po danced on twitter
usa if jim
no three three m usa twitter usa
here emailed back wrong it since the
brutal twitter usa you miss if everybody
in a tweet they'd be the coolest
play okay brian and everybody go back
to county you're doing wrong when i
say well i want everyone to have
a voice
louis louie get in the next meeting
pray we're doing glowy lowy when we
get to the next episode this is
the it'll be to talk about the
beach boys we'll talk about that we
need to talk about the
starring kat tilda swinton um alright and
if you wanna hear ad-free episodes go
fuck yourself because we are never doing
ah no said wellesley yeah go to
stitcher premium or three most atm at
ca cb well maybe world dot com
okay goodbye
a